NOT GOOD ENOUGH
AAAAAAHHHHH!!!!!
What has it all been for?
My army, my subscribers
My legacy
Edgar: You've got it all, Felix
Fame! 50 million subcribers
The number one YouTube channel
and the best dog of all time
Pewds: That's seriously questionable
(lol)
,and that's 57 million thank you very much
Edgar: You spend your days trying to design the perfect pair of headphones?
You are taking this too far
Pewds: Then you should just....
...leave
JUST GO!
I don't want you here
Edgar: oh
oh ok ;_;
Pewds: Why haven't you left then you son of bitch
*swedish thunder*
Edgar: Goodbye
(papa pewds crys in fake rain and swedish thunder)
(metal headbang)
Old pewds: How's it going everyone
Myy name is PewdiePie!
I don't know I can do pretty much anything, if you have a suggestion then leave it down below
But, have a good weekend, and I'll see you pretty soon
Ha-ha *doorbell rings*
Edgar: I'm back Felix.
Felix: Edgar!
Edgar: Look a wow.
Felix: What are these.
Felix: Oh My God!
Edgar: Look a' Wow!! Get your Razer Kraken Bro V2
Custom Made Pewdiepie, trademark headphones
Edgar: Just for you!
Felix: You work with Razor, to make these headphones?
Felix: Wow thank you Edgar!
Edgar:Horay
Felix: I love you Edgar
2x
Edgar: We are going to be super rich.
Felix: We are going to be rich Edgar
2x
These are going to sell, like crazy
Felix: Finally i can finally buy you food, Edgar
Edgar: Huzaah!
Felix: I'm so proud!
(Grunting)
Today's very special
7 years ago before I started making videos
I needed to get a microphone
so I spent some of my last money
went out and bought the Razer Carcharias
and I used to make a ton of my videos
you've seen it and now 7 years later
I have my very own
Razor headphones
Designed by me! :D
It feels unreal
I never thought something like this would happen
So frickin' cool
I love them
The design is amazing
I'm so proud of these
I'm so glad I can finally even wear them
Cause we had to keep it secret for a long time
Let's- oh that's awesome
Let's put them on x2
HELL YEAH!
That's dope
(laugh)
They really are something. They really stand out
I love their design
I'm so- I'm so proud of these
It's the new ones as well that doesn't cover your whole ear- they're more open
aw man they're so comfortable
Uh-
Thank you to everyone for supporting me throughout the years
I never thought something like this would happen obviously-
when I started making videos
just looking back this is so unreal
I've always been a huge fan of Razer and what they do and
their design and I'm glad to be part of that
and to make- design something myself as well
I got the Pewds on the side
got the brofist on the side
I love it
like easily my favorite headphones ever
so yeah if you wanna get these
check em' out in the description
I think that they're super cool so...
-AAAHH! Go buy em'!
I'm just glad I can finally wear them
Thank you guys. Squadfam out!
Sisterfister!
and Brofist.